I just want to touch on the madoff
question here because I'm and the only
question I want to ask about that is you
know what's fascinating to me observing
that from a distance is in any couple
you you know always the most charged
conversations are about money right but
how did you incur navigate that well if
we we've been through a situation
already because we've been married for a
really long time and in our relationship
I made all the money and then she got on
the closer and I wasn't making jack shed
and for seven years
she made all the money so we already had
this kind of like there was a certain
sort of balance about that whole issue
even if I think we were pretty cool
about it from the beginning but even if
we weren't like that really made a great
balance and I think that when the Madoff
thing happened we didn't want to sell
our apartment and we didn't want to sell
you know whatever but we knew we could
you know we be alright we knew we were
gonna have each other and that our kids
were okay they were you know through
school and you know almost we both felt
like we would work and there was so many
people that got hit so much harder than
us and yeah I mean I don't think there
was a moment where that thing happened
and then we got pissed at each other
just that's just it was it was sort of
the opposite we kind of went on we [ __ ]
you know what some you know let's I
don't know let's have sex or something
I don't know it's free it's free
you